[Música]
si sois fieles seguidores de visual
politic seguro que os habéis dado cuenta
de que hay un tema que siempre nos ha
gustado especialmente el petróleo bueno
Y también la Argentina Argentina es
también nuestra perdición ya lo sabéis
El caso es que el crudo sigue teniendo
una enorme influencia en la política
internacional Por eso cada vez que se
descubren grandes yacimientos nuevos
resulta emocionante especialmente si
esto se producen en países en vías de
desarrollo o en países que digamos no
han sido famosos precisamente por sus
recursos energéticos ese suele ser el
preámbulo de muchas historias políticas
y también económicas nos encanta
precisamente este fue el caso de un país
relativamente desconocido y poco poblado
del que ya os hemos hablado varias veces
aquí en visual politic por supuesto
estamos hablando de Guyana la misma
Guyana que ahora se enfrenta al desafío
de la Venezuela bolivariana por el
control de esequivo Sin embargo en esta
ocasión no os vamos a hablar de Guyana
sino de su aún menos conocido vecino
surinam para muchos el país más
prometedor de
[Música]
2024 situado entre la Guyana la Guyana
Francesa y Brasil este país cuyo
territorio está cubierto en un 90 por
por la selva amazónica es uno de los más
pequeños de Sudamérica y también el
menos poblado tan solo tiene unos
600,000 habitantes surinam que fue
primero avistada por Cristóbal Colón en
1498 y colonizada por holandeses a
partir de
1667 es un país que normalmente siempre
ha pasado más bien desapercibido digamos
que no tiene una posición geoestratégica
particularmente relevante no tiene una
economía desarrollada y tampoco cuenta
con recursos de Gran importancia O al
menos eso ha sido así hasta ahora y es
que veréis hace tan solo unos años
surinam pasó de ser un total desconocido
a estar en el punto de mira mundial
después de esta noticia total anuncian
un importante hallazgo de petróleo en
aguas de surinam desde entonces este
país ha estado en el radar tanto de
Grandes petroleras como de muchas
grandes potencias Por qué Pues porque
con los descubrimientos realizados el
oro negro con burbujas de surinam puede
convertirse en uno de los más lucrativos
del mundo hoy la industria Espera que
surinam pueda seguir los exitosos pasos
de Guyana y convertirse en un importante
proveedor de crudo lo que dada su escasa
población podría convertirlo en un país
inmensamente rico queridos amigos amigas
cómo ha llegado surinama hasta este
punto Por qué se están depositando
tantas esperanzas en este pequeño y
desconocido país puede el conflicto por
la guayana esquiva perturbar sus planes
Pues bien ya sabéis gasolina y
arranquemos
por cierto si os gustan todos estos
temas no os podéis perder si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
participamos por ejemplo en el último
vídeo os contamos Cómo Irlanda se ha
hecho rica y también Qué problema existe
con sus cifras de crecimiento que ya os
adelanto están adulteradas también hemos
hablado mucho de petróleo gas y energía
no os lo perdáis os dejamos el link en
la descripción dicho esto
continuemos surinam joven y
turbulenta desde el comienzo de surinam
como país plenamente independiente en
noviembre de 1975 esta ex Colonia
holandesa no ha tenido una historia
realmente fácil la situación del país
como también ocurrió en su vecina uyana
era devastadora con una enorme pobreza y
una economía muy poco productiva poco
desarrollada y basada casi
exclusivamente en la exportación de
minerales la situación era tal que tan
solo 5 años después de su independencia
en 1980 ocurrió lo que siempre suo
ocurrir En estos casos se produjo un
golpe de estado y con ello llegó al
poder la que es seguramente la figura
más importante de la historia política
de esta joven nación des iutar se el
jefe del Consejo militar nacional que
tras el golpe de estado prometió la
vuelta de la Democracia para
1982 sin embargo sin señales de que eso
fuera a suceder ese mismo año miles de
manifestantes tomaron las calles y se
enfrentaron al régimen militar que
decidió ejecutar a 15 manifestantes
opositores tras este altercado toda la
ayuda financiera proveniente de Países
Bajos y Estados Unidos quedó suspendida
inmediatamente lo que supuso una especie
de golpe de Gracia para el país la
economía de surinam quedó estancada
durante mucho tiempo y así las tensiones
sociales y económicas llegaron a tal
punto que en 1985 bautar se accedió a
zar el camino hacia el regreso de la
Democracia algo que finalmente culminó
en el 87 sin embargo Este dictador que
debía de echar de menos el poder volvió
a dar un nuevo golpe de estado en 1990
Eso sí este segundo periodo dictatorial
solo duró apenas unos pocos meses y en
mayo del 91 Se volvieron a celebrar
elecciones tras las presiones de Estados
Unidos y Países Bajos desde entonces la
democracia se ha mantenido estable sin
embargo no se puede decir exactamente lo
mismo de su
economía como podéis ver todo empezó a
cambiar con el nuevo siglo a partir del
año 2001 comenzó el llamado superciclo
de las materias primas es decir el alza
generalizado de los precios de las
materias primas algo por lo que surina
al igual que ocurrió con sus vecinos
sudamericanos se vio muy pero que muy
beneficiado no obstante la época de
Bonanza llegó a su fin en 2015 y surinam
volvió a chocarse con la dura realidad
la minería su principal actividad
económica no era suficiente para salir
adelante sin embargo esperar un momento
porque ese mismo año llegó una noticia
que dio un vuelco de 180 gr a las
esperanzas de este olvidado país deon
Mob anuncia un importante descubrimiento
de petróleo frente a las costas de
Guyana a ver ya desde el siglo XVII se
sabía que había hidrocarburos en la
Cuenca de guayana surinam pero nunca se
había hallado una cantidad significativa
pero como os podéis imaginar una vez que
el oro negro brotó en Guyana el
siguiente objetivo iba a ser surinam y
de esta forma las exploraciones pues
comenzaron en 2016 A ver surinam no es
un país estrictamente nuevo en lo que se
refiere a la exploración y explotación
de crudo ya en 1982 comenzó por ejemplo
a producir sus primeros barriles
actualmente de hecho cuenta con tres
campos petroleros terrestres con unas
reservas en total de unos 100 millones
de barriles que explota la petrolera
estatal State soil ahora bien esos
Campos y pozos quedarían a la altura del
betún a partir de todo lo que se comenzó
a descubrir en el año 2020
[Música]
atentos la esperanza
petrolera 2020 fue un año clave para
surinam y no solo porque también tuvo
que hacer frente a la covid 19 y porque
el exdictador botere perdió las
elecciones tras 10 años en la
presidencia 2020 fue clave para surinam
porque por fin se encontraron los
primeros grandes yacimientos petroleros
en sus aguas los gigantes petroleros
Apache y total energies encontraron las
primeras señales de grandes reservas
petroleras desde entonces han encontrado
hasta cinco yacimientos en el bloque 58
con unas reservas estimadas solo en
estos yacimientos de unos 6,500 millones
de barriles de petróleo una locura si
tenemos en cuenta que el país como os
decíamos solo tiene unos 600,000
habitantes pensad que teniendo en cuenta
el yacimiento terrestre hablamos de unos
12,500 barriles de reservas de crudo per
cápita hablamos por tanto de unos
beneficios potenciales de más de $50,000
por cabeza una cantidad que la mayor
parte iría a parar a las arcas públicas
Pero eso no es todo la historia aún no
ha terminado otras empresas como chebron
shell o la petrolera estatal de Malasia
Petronas también se han apuntado a esta
particular fiesta VIP y están explorando
los diferentes bloques de las aguas de
surinam y sabéis que cada una de ellas
está consiguiendo nuevos y jugosos
descubrimientos Así que como os podéis
imaginar en surinam están pletóricos con
todo esto creen que realmente podrán
replicar El Milagro económico de Guyana
para los que no lo recordéis Guyana
cuenta con unas reservas declaradas de
11,000 millones de barriles en sus
yacimientos submarinos yacimientos que
le han permitido ser la economía que más
rápido ha crecido desde 2022 de hecho
algunos analistas señalan que para 2040
Guyana podría recaudar hasta 160,000
millones de dólares una cantidad
equivalente a $200,000 por habitante tan
solo en los próximos 17 años y eso sin
tener en cuenta el resto de la actividad
económica una auténtica barbaridad no
obstante por el momento surinam no
cuenta con unas reservas estimadas tan
grandes como las declaradas por Guyana
pero con lo que sí cuenta es con un
presidente Chan shantui que está
ofreciendo unas condiciones que se miren
por donde se miren no se pueden
rechazar Y es que veréis ya desde el
comienzo de su mandato y los primeros
grandes descubrimientos en aguas de
surinam santok se ha centrado en hacer
del país un Oasis para la inversión
petrolera por ejemplo en vez de ofrecer
acuerdos de producción con partida de 20
años como hacen muchos de sus vecinos
sudamericanos los está ofreciendo a 30
años lo cual los hace mejores para la
inversión la exploración y la producción
y no solo eso mientras las regalías por
ingresos de las empresas petroleras
rondan el 16 por de media a nivel
internacional santok está ofreciendo
unas regalías de tan solo el 6,25 por.
tan solo un poco más altas que en Guyana
y por si fuera poco el petróleo
submarino de surinam es ligero y Dulce
es decir requiere de menos dinero para
conseguir un buen combustible Pues bien
todas estas condiciones hicieron que en
septiembre de 2023 la petrolera Apache
confirmara que los yacimientos en el
bloque 58 serían rentables de tal forma
que junto a la francesa total energies
invertirán más de 9,000 millones de
dólares para poder empezar a producir en
el año 2028 todo un pelotazo para una
economía fuertemente deprimida como la
de surinam El presidente santok ha
asegurado que el dinero que se vaya a
recaudar por los contratos petroleros va
a ir dirigido a la tan necesaria
diversificación de la economía la
existencia de petróleo y gas es limitada
por lo que tenemos que usar los ingresos
para diversificar la economía para
invertir en agricultura en el sector
turismo en vivienda infraestructura para
un desarrollo sostenible en el futuro
dicho de otra forma el petróleo puede
convertirse en el fin del modelo
económico que ha dominado surinam desde
que era una
[Música]
colonia por supuesto además santoi
también Busca hacer frente a otros
problemas como la pobreza en la que vive
su la mayor parte de la población del
país o el déficit fiscal crónico que ha
llevado a que el gobierno esté hundido
en deudas y su moneda se haya devaluado
significativamente en los últimos años
por el momento santok ya ha logrado con
las proyecciones petroleras en la mano
renegociar la deuda de surinam con
algunos de sus acreedores surinam sale
del default con una deuda vinculada al
petróleo de 660 millones de dólares Eso
sí esperate un momento antes de lanzar
las campanas al vuelo porque la mayoría
de los analistas alerta an de dos
grandes amenazas que pueden echar por
tierra las grandes aspiraciones de los
habitantes de este pequeño y empobrecido
país ahora tan emocionado con todo su
oro negro con burbujas prestad mucha
[Música]
atención el parásito de
surinam amigos al igual que ha venido
pasando en la próspera Guyana una sombra
hace hecha también en surinama la sombra
de la corrupción Como sucede en otros
muchos países del continente americano
surinam es un país eminentemente
corrupto sí es cierto cuenta con algunas
leyes para luchar contra el fraude el
lavado de activos y el contrabando sin
embargo lo cierto Es que todos esos
esfuerzos han resultado inútiles simple
y llanamente porque la figura política
más importante del país se ha lucrado
con todo tipo de negocios ilícitos
hablamos como no del exdictador y ahora
expresidente bouterse que tiene a sus
espaldas más dramas que una serie de hbo
y de hecho es que no hay duda todos los
analistas concuerdan con que bautar se
convirtió surinam en su Cortijo
particular digamos que utilizó todo El
poder del Estado para lucrar con sus
negocios e incluso en algunos casos para
ligarse al crimen organizado
[Música]
internacional y es que veréis tras el
fin de su segundo gobierno militar en
1991 votarse comenzó a construir su
propio imperio criminal estoy hablando
del conocido como carel Suri que se
centra en el tráfico de armas y de
narcóticos de hecho en el 99 fue
condenado a 16 años de prisión en Países
Bajos por delitos precisamente de
narcotráfico y también por el asesinato
de 15 civiles en el 82 y de hecho amigos
bautar es tan buscado que a día de hoy
no puede salir de surinam porque tiene
una orden internacional de arresto
emitida por la europol contra él pero ni
siquiera penséis que es el único que ha
sido juzgado por estos delitos de hecho
sin ir más lejos su hijo mayor Din no
votarse incluso fue apresado y condenado
en 2015 Ni más ni menos que por este
motivo creo que os va a sorprender
fijaos El hijo del líder de surinam
condenado a 16 años de cárcel en Estados
Unidos por ayudar a hezbola en general
digamos que deía tarse supo aprovecharse
de las propicias condiciones para los
negocios ilícitos que ofrece surin Y es
que pensadlo bien estando cubierto en un
90 por la densa selva amazónica este
país supone un gran escondite para el
crimen organizado además su población es
muy pequeña y apenas cuenta con
efectivos policiales que sean capaces de
controlar todas las fronteras de esta
vasta región por lo que el tráfico de
armas drogas y otros bienes pues es
relativamente sencillo Y eso ni siquiera
es todo la corrupción de votarse se ha
filtrado durante estos últimos 40 años
en el resto de las capas del Estado el
resultado Pues que hoy en surinam el
clientelismo y las coimas a funcionarios
son el pan nuestro de cada día de hecho
una de las principales razones por las
que estallaron estas masivas a
principios de 2023 fue precisamente esta
enorme corrupción por eso la mayoría de
los analistas al igual que los propios
ciudadanos de surinam temen que el
dinero del petróleo acabe mayormente en
las manos de los políticos y de los
funcionarios corruptos es cierto el
presidente santoi está intentando
reforzar la lucha contra la corrupción
Pero la realidad es que después de 40
años parasitando al Estado votarse ha
hecho que la tarea sea especialmente
dura y ojo que esta no es la única
amenaza para los futuros ingresos o
incluso para los futuros planes
petroleros del país y es que varios
analistas apuntan a otra amenaza que
tiene que ver precisamente con el
conflicto por la guayana esquiba fijaos
el chavismo gana el referéndum para la
anexión del esequibo y eleva la tensión
con Guyana Venezuela recrudece el
conflicto con Guyana por el esequibo y
da un ultimatum a exon y otros
productores de petróleo amigos el
conflicto del esquivo ha hecho saltar
por los aires la relativa estabilidad de
la que gozaba este territorio tened en
cuenta que si Venezuela llega a cumplir
su promesa y se anexiona su parte de
Guyana este país perdería 74 por de su
actual territorio y a ver parece poco
probable que ocurra Pero qué queréis que
os diga visto lo visto con dictadores
locos y codiciosos nunca se sabe en
cualquier caso los riesgos conviene
tenerlos muy pero que muy en cuenta
precisamente por eso aquí Tenemos que
tener en cuenta que aunque la mayoría de
los pozos que le han dado alas a la
economía de Guyana no están en aguas
territoriales de la guayana esquiva si
este territorio cayera en manos de
Venezuela Guyana perdería importantes
campos petroleros en total perdería tres
de los ocho campos petroleros actuales y
la mitad del más grande y fructífero
hasta el momento el campo State Pro por
eso eso mis queridos amigos de usal
politic hay quien se hace una pregunta
si Venezuela tomara el esequivo
finalmente Sería posible que Guyana
empezar a reclamar o incluso a intentar
tomar territorio de surinam para
compensar sus pérdidas vale en principio
todo apunta que
no las disputas territoriales marítimas
en aguas ricas en petróleo entre Guyana
y surinam ya fueron resueltas en el año
2007 y de hecho el arbitraje
internacional dio un resultado mucho más
favorable a Guyana que a surinam por lo
tanto Guyana no a reclamar aguas de
surinam y en cuanto al territorio
terrestre y es que sí ambos países
mantienen una disputa territorial por
una región situada al sur de ambos
estados la región del tigre sin embargo
la realidad es que Guyana controla este
territorio con sus tropas desde que
incumplió el acuerdo con surinam para
retirarlas en 1971 en síntesis que
frente a lo que algunos analistas
apuntan Lo cierto es que cuyana no
tendría ningún reclamo legítimo ni sobre
las aguas ni sobre ninguna tierra de
surinam por lo tanto frente a lo que
algunos analistas alertan Guyana no
parece que tendría ningún reclamo
legítimo ni sobre las aguas ni sobre
ninguna tierra de surinam y de hecho la
realidad es que ahora mismo no le
convendría tener a surinam en su contra
sobre todo después de esta noticia
surinam apoya a Guyana en su conflicto
con Venezuela pese a problema fronterizo
bilateral sin embargo un momento porque
lo que sí podría ocurrir es que
finalmente los tambores de guerra en la
región frenarán y ralentizará muchas
inversiones lo que evidentemente podría
retrasar los sueños de oro negro de un
país que puede convertirse en uno de los
más prometedores del mundo ya en 2024
así que ya lo veis todo apunta que el
siguiente milagro económico se quedará
en las guayanas Pero esta vez en surinam
la excolonia landesa tiene por delante
una oportunidad de oro y además también
tiene tiempo para prepararse e intentar
corregir muchos de sus grandes problemas
Al fin y al cabo los primeros barriles
de los nuevos Campos no comenzarán a
brotar hasta 2028 Claro que llegados a
este punto ahora la pregunta es para
todos vosotros creéis que surinam
conseguirá replicar el éxito de su
vecina Guyana qué creéis que deberían
hacer frente a la corrupción
generalizada es posible que las grandes
petroleras eviten el conflicto en el
esquivo y en la región podéis dejarnos
como siempre vuestra resp puesta en los
comentarios Y también si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis dar
al botón de like y suscribiros a al
politic si es que aún no lo habéis hecho
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la
próxima